[Musique]
savez vous qu'il y a en france en ce
moment des femmes battues j'ignore
totalement mais il ya certainement eu
depuis toujours j'ai pas d'aujourd'hui
ça a toujours existé ça dépanne battu y
en aura toujours
et c'est un film sur la quantité il y à
des femmes battues c'est sur ce qu'avait
fait des hommes qui sont il ya des
inhumains partout où les gens pensent de
bron table qu'il me cible non j'admets
pas pas du tout absolument pas il aurait
mieux que ça cesse je n'ai jamais venus
battue ma femme je vous jure que c'est
vrai je vous jure se valent et l kimba
évidemment il ya des hommes qui sont
battus ouais je jeu j'ai entendu j'ai
pas vu mais des vents des femmes en
colère qui valence vient de fourchette
une assiette à la tête de leur mari ça
te présente ça mon petit pas mais les
esprits non je permettrai pas ma femme
de le faire d'abord dans certaines
circonstances oui au xxème siècle c
désolant puis le monde est monde des x
men le nom histoire j'avais déjà leur a
certainement plus pas plus que les
femmes mais des hommes valeureux
peut-être puisque d'abord que les femmes
ils vous n'avez jamais jamais baptisé
très franc je n'ai jamais battu ma femme
ma femme ne m'a jamais battu non plus
d'ailleurs
ouais on est tous cas des femmes battues
en france pensais pas je pense que c'est
ce qu'il faut s'attendre des relations
entre les êtres humains et vous monsieur
vous êtes mariés oui vous l'avez été
souvent votre femme
non jamais
jamais jamais jamais jamais non jamais
jamais jamais mais une pas avec une rose
que personnellement je vois pas la
mienne bien que parfois j'en ai revus
vous avez déjà bâti votre faim
battu ce disque 8 et visant oui un coup
malheureux
elle est méritée pas spécialement non un
coup de colère l humilité
alors là ça c'est une chose
oui pas battu c'est surprenant
ça me prendra tellement désinvesti votre
femme au studio 4 x ou y en a qui
viennent des feuilles sont un peu plus
marquée que d'habitude alors c'est
sûrement un accident de ménage sont
taillés dans une casserole c'est
possible des femmes battues j'en connais
pas varié si l'on a envie oui il ya des
femmes qui aiment sa part je crois par
habitude peut-être il y avait un calme
est battu il y en a qui aiment pas il y
en a qui sont pas battus parce qu'elles
n'ont pas besoin d'être battue mais je
sais qu'il ya des femmes qui se font
battre et si je disais que moi je bats
ma femme vous savez j'en tire est plus
amoureuse de moi qu'ils ont compris et
vous que j'en pensais que si mettons moi
si je veux tapé ma femme mais je suis
sûr que la famille l'amour le dialogue
mais pas possible j'ai vu quelques
dessins humoristiques avec encre et vous
entrez vous ça bien dans la tête vous
savez ces dessins avec un marteau alors
à certaines femmes il leur faut faut
leur faire entrer à coups de poing
c'est le résultat du bio statut
patriarcal de l'homme
[Musique]
il ya là droit qui paraît une évidence à
beaucoup de gens et qui qui sont tout à
fait incapable de remettre en question
les relations réelles de l'homme et de
la femme et s'apercevoir que la femme
aussi est une personne comme l'écrivait
la revue esprit
il ya bien des années
[Musique]